rockets launched it by forces loyal to
warlord Khalifa Haftar
injured civilians in several districts
of Libya's capital the barrage of
rockets was in retaliation for the
offensive by those backing Lee and
recognized the government in Tripoli to
recapture tahuna the city around 90
kilometers southeast of Tripoli is
heffter the major stronghold in the west
of the country and the operations
headquarters of the year-long campaign
to capture the capital we've launched
this attack to cut the supply line
coming to their positions in southern
Tripoli we advanced 27 kilometers inside
the administrative borders of tahuna and
are now in control of the area
government forces say they killed some
pro hefter fighters and captured dozens
of prisoners in Saturday's advance on
Taruna we advanced from several axes we
captured a number of their forces
weapons and military vehicles the move
was ordered by our operation room we
will win the battle
the majority of Hefner's forces fighting
in the suburbs of southern Tripoli come
from tahuna many of them abandoned the
battle to seize Tripoli to return home
to defend their city the pullout has
helped government forces make gains in
other front lines half those forces lost
many areas along the coast of Western
Olivia last week the battle for tahuna
is seen as crucial because if it falls
into the hands of the internationally
recognized the government it signals the
downfall of Hefner's forces in the
entire area Mahmoud Abdul Wahid al
Jazeera Tripoli